Jenna you were in a fridge the other
time you were balancing tortillas on
your head so you try to keep it light
and fun in between Texas now I actually
do stuff like that to scare myself you
know I told you know I don't want to
draw anything on the floor I feel like
in the fridge it's really isolating as
soon as the doors closed and it's dark
in there and she uses it to get into
characters seriously yeah seriously well
because it's like it's a moment of
resetting right before take so there's
no distractions you know anything it's
just you with your thoughts and you get
the time to really amp yourself up girl
that's the method acting right there
almost